deux enfants sont sortis en courant de la
brousse je pense qu'ils venaient de l'avion
mais et puis nous avons commencé à courir dans
la brousse cette zone d'où cela venait
quinze les deux quinze vingt minutes
plus tard nous entendons des bruits d'autres personnes
criant il y a une femme qui voix  tout
ça et puis nous avons suivi cette voix
jusqu'à ce que nous arrivions à la zone où se trouvait cet
avion quand je suis arrivé et il
y avait quelques personnes à l'intérieur, il y avait
trois personnes coincées là-dedans je ne peux pas l'
avoir oh c'est propre et tout ça  et
avec tout cela, continuez à m'appeler et à circuler
pour vous entraider et vous dire à
quoi ressemblent des femmes quelque chose comme ça,
je dis que c'est parce que je n'ai jamais
vu quelque chose comme ça de toute ma
vie, mais nous l'avons juste fait car tout le monde est
vivant au  très à pied au
maintien de
vous